GEO COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
TODAY'S HEARING -- THE PERSON
TODAY SIR TRAVEL STATE GAMING
COMPACT.
BEFORE US.
IS ONE WHICH WAS EXECUTED
OCTOBER NINETEENTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BETWEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE HOPE OF OUR
TRIBE.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
PRINCIPAL ARCHITECTS OF THAT
CONTACT.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE TRIBE.
THE CONTACT AUTHORIZES THE TRIBE
OPERATE A MAXIMUM THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE SLOT MACHINES AT
NO MORE THAN.
TWO GAMING FACILITIES LOCATED ON
ELIGIBLE INDIAN LANDS HELD IN
TRUST FOR THE TRIBE.
THE DRIVERS AGREED TO PAY THE
STATE HAD ITS SHARE OF THE COST
THE STATE INCURS FOR THE
PERFORMANCE OF ITS DUTIES ON THE
CONTACT.
THE CONTACT IS NOT REQUIRED THE
TRIED TO PAY INTO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND OR THE TRIBAL
NATION GRANT FUND.
CERTAIN TERMS OF THE COMPACT
RELATED LICENSING REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT A MITIGATION PATRON
PROTECTION LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROVISIONS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY THE SAME AS RECENT
COMPACTS HAS BEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANNA REMIND ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES NO FORMAL
VOTE WILL BE TAKEN TODAY TODAY'S
HEARING IS FOR THIS COMMITTEE BE
BRIEFED ON THE CONTENTS OF THE
COMPACT.
AS IT CANNOT BE AMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR BY SIR
REQUIRES RATIFICATION BILL FOR
THIS COMPACT AND AT SOME POINT.
IT WILL BE TAKEN UP FOR
CONSIDERATION BY THE ENTIRE BODY
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME ALL
TODAY'S PANELISTS PARTICIPANTS --
AND WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LET'S
BEGIN THE HEARING I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THE GOVERNOR'S TRAVEL TO
GO CHASING VISOR.
AS WELL AS WELL SHE'S ME SHE'S
REPLACING MEMBERS JOE DILLON WHO
WAS APPOINTED JUDGE OF THE
SECULAR COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
GOVERNOR BROWN AND I NEVER SAW
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING -- AS THE CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED MY NAME IS ANNA NAY
MARK AND I'M THE GOVERNOR'S
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER --
GOOD MORNING TO CHAIRMAN GRAY
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S REALLY NICE TO
SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY.
THE TRIBE IN THE STATE ENTERED
INTO A TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WHICH ENABLE THE TRIBE THROUGH
REVENUES GENERATED.
BY ITS CASINO TO SUPPORT A
STRONG SELF SUFFICIENT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND TO FIND ESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES TO ITS
CITIZENS.
IN LIGHT OF THE UPCOMING
EXPIRATION OF THAT CONTACT THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED
AND SIGNED A NEW CONTRACT WITH
THE WHO BUT TRIED.
THIS COMPACT SUPPORTS TRIBAL AND
STATE INTERESTS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH RECENT CONTACTS
RATIFIED BY THIS LEGISLATURE.
SO THE NEW SUBMIT MINISTRATION
SUPPORTS ITS RATIFICATION.
THE ECONOMIC PROVISIONS AS NOTED
BY CHAIRMAN GRAY ALLOW FOR THE
TRIBE TO OPERATE UP TO THREE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMING
DEVICES AND APPS TO FACILITIES.
THE COMPACT REQUIRES A TRIBE
KATE'S PRO RATA SHARE INTO THE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND COSTS
WHICH COVER REGULATORY COSTS.
BUT THOSE WILL BE DELAYED UNTIL
JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE TRIBE IS
NOT REQUIRED TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
AND WILL INSTEAD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAYMENTS UNDER THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND AND THE
TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FUNDS.
THE OTHER COURT PROVISIONS OF
THE COMPACT INCLUDING TERMS
RELATED TO LICENSING REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND PROTECTION.
ARE SIMILAR TO THOSE IN OTHER
CONTACTS NEGOTIATED BY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THROUGH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS AGAINST WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
PROVISIONS TO ADOPT TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT AND INCLUSION OF
THE STATE'S MINIMUM WAGE RATES.
THE TRY WILL ADOPT A STANDARD
TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE
THE CONTACT ALSO INCLUDE SIMILAR
PROVISIONS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION EXCEPT THE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT WILL
BE WITH THE STATE RATHER THAN
THE COUNTY BECAUSE OF THAT THE
LAND SIZE THAT IS OF THE TRIBE
OF COOPER.
AND THE RELATIVE REMOTENESS OF
THE LOCATION.
BUT IN THIS WILL BE BASED ON
DETERMINATION OF IMPACTS IN THE
TRIBAL ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REVIEW.
THE CONTACTS TERM IS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH YEAH NUMBER.
WE CANNOT MOVE ON TO THE TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AUDIBLE CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS RYAN JACKSON I'M THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE VALLEY TRIBE.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR
A WHICH WILL RATIFY AMENDMENTS
TO THE VALLEY TRIBES GAMING
COMPACT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH TO THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE
FOR AS LONG TIME SUPPORT WHO
VALLEY TRIBE AS WILLINGNESS TO
SPONSOR OUR RATIFICATION BILL.
SOME BACKGROUND VALLEY TRIBE IN
HUMBLE COUNTY AS ONE OF THE
LARGEST TRUST LAND BASES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND HAS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
POPULATIONS PROBLEM MEMBERS.
TRY TO BUSINESSES INCLUDE ARE
OPEN MANY MORE.
I PUBLIC UTILITIES DISTRICT.
DISABLED IN MOTEL LUCKY BEAR
CASINO.
AND HOOPER FORCED INDUSTRIES.
THESE BUSINESSES ARE CRUCIAL TO
THE TRIBE ECONOMY IS A PROVIDE
GOOD SERVICES AND JOBS TO THE
COMMUNITY. TO ENSURE THAT LUCKY
BURKE CASINO CAN CONTINUE TO
OPERATE SLOT MACHINES SENATE
BILL.
SIX SEVENTY FOUR CODIFY THE
EXISTING COMPACT THAT THE VALLEY
TRIBE AGREED UPON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR.
TODAY THE VALLEY TRIBES THRIVING
WITH APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE WHO TRAVEL MEMBERS.
THE TRIBE OWNS SEVERAL
ENTERPRISES THAT OPERATE ON THE
RESERVATION.
INCLUDING LIKE UBER CASINO.
ALL ACT AS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THE VALLEY'S ECONOMY.
THE CASINO CURRENTLY OPERATES
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND A HUNDRED
THIRTY MACHINES ON THE GAMING
FLOOR AND IT'S TWENTY EMPLOYEES
WELL WHICH ARE HOOPER TROUBLE
MEMBERS.
THE LAST CONTACT WAS RATIFIED IN
SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY
NINE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
TRIBES COMPACT WAS GREAT UPON.
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN.
I THE NEW COMPACT THIS BILL
CODIFIES A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TROUBLE CONTACT BETWEEN STATE OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO BELLY TRIBE SO
THEY CAN OPERATE LOOKING BEAR
CASINO.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE TRIBE TO OPERATE UP TO
THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE GAMING
SEEMS TO HAVE UP TO TWO CASINOS.
ON THE TRIBES TRUST LANDS.
THE COMPACT INCLUDES UPDATED
PROVISIONS FOR LICENSING
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT
MITIGATION OF OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS.
AND PROTECTIONS FOR PATRONS
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER RECENT COMPAQ'S.
BECAUSE THE TRIBE PLANS ARE
EXTREMELY REMOTE THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO OPERATES REASON NO
OFFERS A RECENT IMPACT OF THE
TRIBE'S CASINO.
THIS COMPACT AMENDMENT WILL
ALLOW THE TRIBE TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE OR SMALL GAMING FACILITY
FOR ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THE STATE HAS AGREED TO WAIVE
THE COST REGULATORY FEES TO THE
STATE FOR FIVE YEARS BECAUSE
LACKEY BURKE CASINO IS SO SMALL.
AND THE LIGHT OF THE FACT.
THAT THE TRIBE AGREED TO UPDATE
THE REGULATORY PROVISIONS FROM
THE NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPAQ.
IS OUR HOPE THAT WITH PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
LAST YEAR THAT WE WILL NOT BE
OBLIGATED TO PAY REGULATORY
COSTS IN THE FUTURE.
THE INCREASED COST OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE UPDATED REGULATORY
PROVISIONS WILL HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON CASINO REVENUES WHICH
PROVIDES JOBS TO TRAVEL MEMBERS.
THE STATE RECOGNIZED THAT THE
TRIBE SHOULD NOT BE REQUIRED TO
PAY REGULATORY COSTS IN LIGHT OF
THE BURDEN.
IT WOULD HAVE ON THE TRIBE IN
THE LIGHT OF THE FACT THE TRIBE
NOT PAY SUCH COSTS FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS.
THE TRIBE REGULATORY ABILITY HAS
PROVEN TO BE MORE THAN ADEQUATE
TO ENSURE THAT THE GAMING
FACILITIES OPERATED IN A MANNER
THAT PROTECTS PUBLIC SAFETY
ENSURES THE INTEGRITY OF THE
GAMING CONDUCTED THERE AND WE
ARE PLEASED THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOME AND HIS NEW TRAVEL
NEGOTIATOR AND NAY MARK.
OUR SUPPORT OF THIS FRAMEWORK.
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT SENATE BILL
SIX SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR GRAB.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACK
RIBBON I REPRESENT UNITE HERE
THE HOTEL AND CASINO WORKERS
UNION.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED WITH
THE WAY -- THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION BEGAN TO APPROACH
THE ISSUE OF TRIBAL GAMING
COMPACTS REDUCING -- FINANCIAL
BURDENS ON TRIBES.
IN A TIME BEFORE THAT WERE SORT
OF LIFTED UP TO USE IS A FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR THE STATE BUDGET.
AND IN OUR VIEW THAT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE BUT NOT OUR
DECISION THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION TURN THAT AROUND --
APPROPRIATELY IN OUR VIEW AND AT
THE SAME TIME.
CREATED SOME ADDITIONAL HIGHER
STANDARDS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO ORGANIZE.
SHOULD THEY EVER CHOOSE TO DO
THAT SO WE THINK THAT SAID THE
DOUBLE APPROACH IS IS THE RIGHT
ONE WE SUPPORT.
THE HOOPER VALLEY TRIBES COMPAQ --
AND WE HOPE HE WE WE GET A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OUT OF THE IS
ASSEMBLY WHEN IT HITS THE FLOOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GROUP AND WE
HAVE -- ANY OTHER TESTIMONY
TODAY.
FROM THE PUBLIC.
SIGNAL BRING IT BACK.
THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
THE QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
I'VE GOT.
TO SOMETHING THERE FOR A MISS
NAY MARK COULD.
GIVE US COMMON UPDATE ON TRAVEL
NATION GAMING FUND WHERE WE'RE
AT AND NO WITH FOR NOT PAYING
INTO THE OUT OF THIS PARTICULAR
CONTACT JUST BE NICE TO SEE.
THE COMMITTEE WORKED ON THAT
ISSUE LAST SESSION AND GIVE US
AN UPDATE THAT BE GREAT.
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
GRAY -- IT'S SOMETHING THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TRIBAL ADVISER
CRISTINA SNYDER -- HAS BEEN
CONVENING AND THE PANEL WHICH
HAS ALL BEEN SELECTED SO THEY'VE
HAD TWO MEETINGS AND THEY'RE ALL
OPEN FOR A MEETING SO IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO COME PARTICIPATE
THEY'RE MORE THAN WELCOME -- I
WAS ABLE TO GO TO THE FIRST ONE
WHICH IS VERY PRODUCTIVE AND SO
IN THOSE MEETINGS THIS SORT OF
INITIAL.
PANEL IS TRYING TO SET OUT THE
RULES OF THE ROAD FOR HOW THIS
WILL GO MOVING FORWARD.
AND ESTABLISH THE GUIDELINES
BECAUSE MOST IMPORTANTLY TO US
IS THAT THIS IS TRIBALLY LEAD --
SO IT IS COMPLETELY -- BASED ON
TRIBAL BEATER HAD VIEWS ABOUT
HOW YOU KNOW WHERE THE SORT OF
RULES AND AND GUIDELINES SHOULD
BE.
AND THERE IT THE PANEL IS
MEETING MONTHLY AND THE NEXT
TEAM GF MEETING WOULD BE
SCHEDULED FOR NINE AM ON FRIDAY
JULY TWELFTH IF ANYONE IS
INTERESTED -- SO -- THERE'S AN
ANTICIPATED APPLICATION
SOLICITATION -- THIS FALL --
SORT OF DEPENDING A LITTLE BIT
ON PROGRESS AND THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF THIS YEAR'S GRANT AWARDS WILL
HOPEFULLY BE IN THE WINTER.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU AND CAN YOU
EXPAND A BIT ON THE GENERAL
SCOPE OF OUR CLASS THREE GAMING.
AUTHORIZES COME BACK IN THE NEW
ONE SISTER.
YES SO THE THE TRIBE IS
AUTHORIZED -- AND PERMITTED ONLY
TO OPERATE THE GAMING DEVICES
WHICH ARE EXPLICIT IN THE
COMPACT AND THAT FLOOR ACTUALLY
FLOWS FROM THE CONSTITUTION.
AND SO ON THAT IS ANY BANK TO OR
PERCENTAGE CARD GAMES -- ANY
DEVICES ARE GAMES ARE AUTHORIZED
UNDER STATE LAW TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY -- AND
THEN IF THE TRIBE IS INTERESTED
THEY CAN ALSO SEPARATELY
NEGOTIATE OFF TRACK WAGERING.
AND SORRY ALSO SLOT MACHINES THE
DRUG OVER THE STATE LOTTERY
PEACE AGAIN SAY THAT.
SO THEY ARE ALLOWED TO OPERATE
ANY AND GAMES THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED UNDER THE STATE LAW
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
PROVIDED THAT THEY WILL NOT.
DO THAT THROUGH THE USE OF THE
INTERNET -- YEAH -- AND I'M
HAPPY TO SORT OF GET BACK TO YOU
FURTHER IF THERE'S MORE DETAIL
SPECIFICALLY YOU WANT ON THAT
BUT THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL LAW.
AS I UNDERSTAND IS THAT RIGHT
YEAH SO THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT.
STATES THAT -- THE STATE CAN
NEGOTIATE WITH THE TRIBE --
GAMES THAT ARE AUTHORIZED FOR
THAT ARE LEGAL WITHIN THAT STATE
AND SO IT IS OUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT -- WHAT CAN BE --
NEGOTIATED FOR UNDER THE COMPACT
HAS TO BE LEGAL IN THAT STATE
AND SO THAT FLOWS BOTH FROM THE
LEGALIZATION OF LOTTERY AND THE
THE LEGALIZATION OF BEING TO
PERCENTAGE GAMES AS WELL AS SLOT
MACHINES UNDER THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
AND YOU MENTIONED ONLINE.
LOTTERY NOT THEY'RE NOT NOT
ALLOWED TO USE THE INTERNET.
AND IS THAT CONSISTENT THROUGH --
MOST STATES CHARTER STANDING OR
DO SOME OFFER ONLINE LOTTERY
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU -- AS I
SAID IN MY INTRODUCTION WILL BE
TAKING THIS UP ON THE ASSEMBLY
FOR IN THE NEAR FUTURE -- MISTER
GRIFFIN AND THIS NEIGHBOR HE
COULD STAY PUT A WE HAVE ANOTHER
CONTACTED YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
OKAY MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE MOVE TO THE THE COMPACT TO
SAY CALIFORNIA AND THE
SUSANVILLE INDIAN RANCHERIA --
THIS COMPACT FOR US -- WAS
EXECUTE OCTOBER NINETEENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BETWEEN GOVERNOR
BROWN.
AND THE SUSANVILLE INDIAN
RANCHERIA -- WE WILL HEAR FROM
PRINCE PARK TAXES WE JUST DID ON
THE REVIOUS CONTACT -- THIS
PARTICULAR CAR BACK AUTHORIZES A
TRIED TO OPERATE A MAXIMUM OF
TWELVE HUNDRED SLOT MACHINES AT
NO MORE THAN TWO GAME FACILITIES
LOCATOR ELIGIBLE LAND.
THE TRIBES AGREED TO PAY -- THE
COSTA STATE CURSED INFORMANTS OF
ITS DUTIES -- THE TRIED AND
STATE ENTERED INTER TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WHICH IS ABLE TO TRIED TO
REVENUES GENERATED BY ITS
DIAMOND MOUNTAIN CASINO HOTEL
BREWERY. TO PROMOTE A STRONG
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT SELF
SUFFICIENCY ENTERPRISE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES TO ITS
MEMBERS -- AGAIN REMIND EVERYONE
THERE'S NO FORMAL VOTE TODAY
WILL TAKE THIS UP ON THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE NEAR FUTURE AND
WITH THAT.
MS NAY MARK TO GIVE A SEDUCTION.
HELLO AND THE NAME MARK -- THE
GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS
ADVISER -- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY -- THE
TRIBE AND STATE ENTERED INTO A
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
ENABLED THE TRIBE THROUGH THE
REVENUES GENERATED BY THE CASINO
TO SUPPORT STRONG SELF
SUFFICIENT TRIBAL GOVERNMENT.
AND TO FUND ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES TO ITS CITIZENS IN
LIGHT OF THE UPCOMING EXPIRATION
OF THAT CONTACT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION NEGOTIATED AND
SIGNED A NEW COMPACT WITH THE
SUSANVILLE TRIED.
THIS COMPACT SUPPORTS TRIBAL AND
STATE INTERESTS AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH RECENT CONTACTS
RATIFIED BY THIS LEGISLATURE SO
THE NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS ITS RATIFICATION.
THE ECONOMIC PROVISIONS ALLOW
FOR THE TRIBE TO OPERATE UP TO
TWELVE HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES IN
UP TO TWO FACILITIES THE COMPACT
REQUIRES THE TRIBE PATES PRO
RATA SHARE OF SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND COSTS.
THE TRIBE IS NOT REQUIRED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE REVENUE
SHARING TRUST FUND BUT IF IT
DECIDES TO GO ABOVE THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE TO THE
DEVICES IT WILL NO LONGER BE
CONSIDERED A LIMITED GAMING
TRIBE.
AND WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND OR
TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT FUND
DOLLARS.
THE OTHER CORPORATIONS OF THE
COMPACT OR SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
TO THE PROVISIONS I DESCRIBED
EARLIR AND WHO BOUGHT INCLUDING
TERMS RELATED TO LICENSING
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
TERM AN ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
BUT THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
AGREEMENT -- RELATED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES -- WILL BE
WITH THE COUNTY RATHER THAN THE
STATE AS IT IS WITH WHO BUT THE
TRIBES HOTEL -- IS HEAVILY
FREQUENTED BY HUNTERS SO
SOMETHING THAT IS UNIQUE TO THE
SUSANVILLE CONTACT IS THAT IN
ADDITION TO THE NORMAL
PROHIBITION ON NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT POSSESSION OF
WEAPONS AT A GAMING FACILITY.
IT ALLOWS OVERNIGHT GUESTS AT
THE HOTEL TO TRANSPORT AND STORE
UNLOADED WEAPONS AND AMMUNITION
IN THEIR HOTEL ROOMS.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. TO HEAR FROM THE
TRUCK.
M. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE --
GREETINGS CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DINA BEAUVAIS I AM
THE CHAIRWOMAN OF THE SUSANVILLE
INDIAN RANCHERIA -- AS YOU HAD
ASK QUESTIONS EARLIER I ALSO AM
A PANELIST -- OF THE TRIBAL
NATIONS GRANT FUND AND HAVE
ATTENDED BOTH OF THOSE MEETINGS --
AND WILL BE ATTENDING AT LEAST
ONCE A MONTH -- FOR THE REST OF
THIS YEAR -- I ALSO CO CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES -- OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS TRIBAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE -- AND WE MEET ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS -- I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF A LOT OF OTHER
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES AND THOSE
ARE THE TWO STATE COMMITTEES
THAT I THAT I'M ACTUALLY A
MEMBER OF THIS IS A REAL INDIAN
RANCHERIAS LOCATED.
IN SUSANVILLE CALIFORNIA --
WITHIN LASSEN COUNTY THE TRIBE
CONSISTS OF MY DO PARA RIVER AND
WASH OF PEOPLE.
THE TRIBE IS COMPRISED OF OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED MEMBERS.
OUR RESERVATION HAS GROWN
STEADILY.
FROM THE THIRTY ACRES AND
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE TO OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED EIGHT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ACRES TODAY.
THROUGH DONATIONS PURCHASES AND
FEDERAL ENTRANCE LAND TRANSFERS --
LASSEN COUNTY CHALLENGES WE ARE
AN EXTREMELY RURAL AREA.
WE SUFFER FROM HIGH POVERTY
RATES AS OF TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
THERE WERE ONLY THREE HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT EMPLOYERS AND
LASSEN COUNTY.
THE TRIBES DIAMOND MOUNTAIN
CASINO AND HOTEL IS AMONG THE
LARGEST PRIVATE EMPLOYER IN THE
REGION.
MOST AREA RESIDENTS WORK FOR THE
FEDERAL AND STATE PRISONS -- OR
COUNTY OR STATE CALTRANS OR A
LOT OF THE COUNTY DEPARTMENTS --
THERE ARE LIMITED -- TO AND
THEY'RE LIMITED OUR
ENTERTAINMENT AND DINING OPTIONS
ESPECIALLY AND SUSANVILLE AND OR
ANY OTHER PLACE UNLESS AGAIN.
AND THEY'RE ALSO MUCH SMALLER
THAN SUSANVILLE -- THE TRIBE IS
OPERATED THE DIAMOND MOUNTAIN
CASINO SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND HAS GRADUALLY EXPANDED THE
INITIAL SIX THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT.
OF FACILITY OUT IN A RESTAURANT
HOTEL AND MOST RECENTLY A
MICROBREWERY.
THE HOTEL IS THE ONLY GREEN
CERTIFIED HOTEL WITHIN LASSEN
COUNTY AND SERVICE FEDERAL AND
STATE EMPLOYEES TRAVELING
THROUGHOUT THE AREA.
WHILE THE TRIBE HAS EXPANDED THE
AMENITIES AND ENTERTAINMENT
OPTIONS AT THE CASINO IT HAS
REMAINED UNLIMITED GAMING TRIBE.
CURRENTLY OFFERING APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED CLASS THREE GAMING
DEVICES AND LIMITED TABLE GAMES.
THE CASINO HAS HAD A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY OF THE
REGION AND THE COMMUNITY OF THE
REGION.
THE CASINOS EVENT SPACE SPACES
HOSTS A MULTITUDE OF FUND
RAISERS AND COMMUNITY EVENTS.
THE DIAMOND MOUNTAIN CASINO
GIVES AWAY APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. TO
LOCAL CHARITABLE CAUSES.
THE TRIBES GAMING ENTERPRISE
ALSO PROVIDES EMPLOYMENT TO FOR
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE PEOPLE
ONE HUNDRED OF STE AND SIX OF
WHOM ARE NOT TRIBAL MEMBERS.
THE DIAMOND NOT JUST YOU KNOW
GIVES AWAY -- SO THERE IN GAMING
REVENUES ALSO SUPPORT VITAL
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS SUCH
AS EDUCATION CHILD CARE AND
ELDER SERVICES FOR THE TRAVEL
THE TRIBAL MEMBERS.
THE TRIBE ALSO PAYS THE CITY OF
SUSANVILLE -- UP.
TO ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO OFFSET THE
COSTS FOR SERVICES PROVIDED TO
THE CASINO AND THE TRIBE.
WITHIN SUSANVILLE CITY LIMITS.
THE CITY IS SUSAN BILLS POLICE
CHIEF COULD NOT ATTEND TODAY --
DUE TO A SCHEDULING CONFLICT
HOWEVER HE HAS PROVIDED A
WRITTEN STATEMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE WHICH I
WILL READ NOW.
GREETINGS I AM HONORED TO WRITE
THIS LETTER OF SUPPORT FOR THE
SUSANVILLE INDIAN RANCHERIA AND
DIAMOND MOUNTAIN TO SEE NOW.
AS A FORTY THREE YEAR RESIDENT
OF SUSANVILLE A THIRTY YEAR LAW
ENFORCEMENT VETERAN AND CURRENT
POLICE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF
SUSANVILLE.
I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED AS A
PARTNER WITH THE SUSANVILLE
INDIAN RANCHERIA FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS.
AS A COMMUNITY MEMBER I HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN CIVIC
ORGANIZATIONS ALONG WITH YOUTH
MIDDLE HIGH SCHOOL COACHING FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS.
DURING THOSE YEARS I HAVE SEEN
THE INCREASE IN SIZE OF THE
DIAMOND ON CASINO AS WELL AS
INCREASING BLEAK.
INCREASING CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
SUSANVILLE INDIAN RANCHERIA AND
DIAMOND NOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE THE
FIRST TO COME TO THE COMMUNITIES
NEEDS IN TIMES OF TRAGEDY
TRAGEDY OR HELP OR HELP.
DIAMOND MOUNT THIS YOU KNOW HAS
PROVIDED -- HOSTED ENDLESS
FUNDRAISERS FOR MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY IN NEED WHETHER IT IS
FUNDRAISING FOR MEDICAL ISSUE.
HELP A FOR HELPING A FAMILY FOR
A NOBLE CAUSE.
DIAMOND MEMPHIS YOU KNOW IS
ALWAYS THERE TO HELP.
DEMOCRACY NO IS THE MOST
FAMILIAR SPONSOR FOR OUR ENTIRE
COMMUNITY.
THEY AND THE SUSANVILLE INDIAN
RANCHERIA PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
SUIT TO CIVIC GROUPS YOUTH
GROUPS SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
COMMUNITY EVENTS ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
IT WOULD BE RARE TO ATTEND AN
EVENT IN SUSANVILLE AND NOT SEE
A WATER BOTTLE WITH THE DIAMOND
MOUNTED CASINO LABEL.
AND IS MOST LIKELY BEEN DONATED.
THEY HAVE COME TO THE
COMMUNITIES RESCUE ON MORE THAN
ONE OCCASION TO HELP BECAUSE AS
THE POLICE OF CHIEF MY
INTERACTION WITH THE CIVIL
INDIAN RANCHERIA DATES BACK
THIRTY YEARS.
WE MEET REGULARLY WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE RANCHERIA AND
THEY HOSTED QUARTERLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLABORATION. TO
DISCUSS ISSUES AND TRENDS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT ONCE
COLLABORATED WITH THE RANCHERIA
TO HIRE NATIVE NATIVE AMERICAN
POLICE OFFICER.
IN A PARTNERSHIP.
RECENTLY THE RANCHERIA HAS
GRACIOUSLY DON'T PROVIDED
VEHICLES THAT WE WILL HAPPILY
PLACE THEIR LOGO ON TO SHOW OUR
PARTNERSHIP.
WE JUST PURCHASED TWO VEHICLES --
EACH OF THOSE VEHICLES -- COST
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO WE HAVE PAID
FOR THOSE BOTH IN FULL --
MEMBERS OF THE DIAMOND MOUNTAIN
CASINO WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND EFFORTS TO
PREVENT ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AT THE
CASINO AND IF DISCOVERED WORK
TOGETHER TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THESE ARE VERY THESE ARE JUST
EXAMPLES OF HOW THIS IS A INDIAN
RANCHERIA HAS PROMOTED AND
SUPPORTED LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY.
IN CLOSING SUSANVILLE INDIAN
RANCHERIA AND THE DIAMOND MOUNT
CASINO HAVE BEEN AN ASSET TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THEY HAVE BEEN A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON OUR COMMUNITY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS I MEASURE THE
DIAMOND MOUNTAIN CASINOS VALUE
BY EVALUATING WHAT THEY WOULD.
WHAT WOULD OCCUR IF THEY WERE
NOT HERE I CAN ASSURE YOU IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACT OUR COMMUNITY IN MANY
WAYS?
UNFORTUNATELY NOT IN A POSITIVE
MANNER WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
SIZZLE INDIAN RANCHERIA AND I'M
IN MOUNT CASINO RESPECTFULLY
KEVIN ALL JONES CHIEF OF POLICE.
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED GAMING
MARKET AND DIM PROSPECTS FOR
EXPANSION THE TRIBE IS MADE
PROACTIVE INVESTMENTS AND NON
GAMING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT --
OPPORTUNITIES THE TRIBE OWNS AND
OPERATES ENTERPRISES IN DIVERSE
FIELDS FROM PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
AND ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION TO
MEDICAL STAFFING SCREEN PRINTING
AND APPAREL SERVICES.
THE TRIBES ENTERPRISES HAVE
REPURPOSE PORTIONS OF AN ARMY
SUB.
ARMY DEPOT IS NEARBY IN HER LONG
CALIFORNIA -- AND THIS WAS
RECEIVED UNDER THE BRACH.
UP PROCESS.
AND NOW WE ARE -- WE HAVE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOMES THAT
ARE.
ANYWHERE FROM 9821100% OCCUPANCY
AT ALL TIMES.
AND WE HAD TO DO A LOT OF WORK
TO BRING THOSE BACK UP THEY WERE
IN HORRIBLE CONDITION WHEN WE
RECEIVE THEM -- THE LESSON AND
IN HOUSE CENTER MANAGED BY THE
TRIBE PROVIDES SORELY NEEDED
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED POPULATION.
OF WE ARE.
PROBABLY THE SECOND OF LARGEST
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER THAT
ACCEPTS MEDICARE HOW WE KNOW
MEDICARE THAT'S MEDICAID AND
CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR PARTNERSHIP IN OUR AREA --
THE TRIBE ALSO OWNS A NUMBER
VENTURES WITH A NATION WIDE
REACH INCLUDING FOR TRIBES
CONSTRUCTION SERVICES.
OF ATI DESPITE OUR EXTENSIVE
EFFORTS AT NON GAMING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GAMING REVENUES ARE
A VITAL FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
TRIBES GOVERNMENT.
THE CREW THE TRIBE CURRENTLY
OPERATES OPERATES ITS GAMING
FACILITY UNDER IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT WHICH IS SET TO EXPIRE
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE WHAT ALLOW THE TRIBE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE IT'S SMALL
GAMING FACILITY UNDER A NEW
TRIBAL STATE COMPACT.
I ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VENTURA MISTER -- EGG
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN -- JACK
RIBBON WITH UNITE HERE -- THE
HOTEL AND CASINO WORKERS UNION
AND JUST TO UNDERSCORE AGAIN
THAT FROM THE CHAIR WOMAN'S
PRESENTATION.
NOT RELYING ON TRIBAL MONEY TO
FUND OUR GENERAL FUND GIVES
TRIBES THE ABILITY TO INVEST IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
MEMBERS.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT THE THE
EXPANSION OF THE RIGHTS OF
WORKERS TO ORGANIZE SHOULD THEY
SO CHOOSE AT SOME POINT.
ALSO SHOWS RESPECT FOR THE
ENGINE BEHIND THESE CASINOS AND
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION. FOR TAKING ON
THE VIEW IT SEEMS TO US THAT THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION HAD ON
THESE CONTACTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MALL.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC. ONE MORNING ALL MY
NAME IS ROBERT JOSEPH ON THE
DISTRICT TO COUNCILMEMBER FOR
THE SUSAN WILLINGDON RANCHERIA.
HERE ON BEHALF WITH -- WITH OUR
TRIBAL CHAIRWOMAN -- I THINK ONE
OF THE BIGGEST THINGS THAT WE
HAVE GOING ON WITH OUR WITH WITH
OUR CASINOS STUFF IS THAT.
IS THAT WE PUT A LOT OF WERE
WERE OR NOT A PER CAPITA TRIBE
WE DON'T GIVE OF MONEY OUT TO
THE TRIBAL MEMBERS.
BUT WHAT WE DO FOCUS ON IS
EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A A PROGRAM FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS AND STUFF FOR
PEOPLE TO GO TO SCHOOL WELL.
IN IN -- WE PAY THEM YOU KNOW AS
LONG AS THEY KEEP THEIR GREAT
THIS STUFF UP.
WE HAVE -- I NINETY FIVE PLUS
PERCENT.
RETURN ON THIS WHICH IS HUGE TO
US BECAUSE YOU KNOW FOR US
EDUCATION THERE'S THERE'S NO NO
LIMIT TO THAT -- IN IN I THINK
THE THE BIGGEST THING FOR US IS
IS IS A TRIBE IS -- OUR GOAL OF
SELF SUFFICIENCY YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT EACH AND EVERYONE
OF OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS TO BE AS
IS SELF SUFFICIENT.
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE -- TO RELY
ON ANYBODY BUT THEMSELVES -- AS
A TRIBAL COUNCIL MEMBER I SAID
ON OUR HOUSING BOARD AS WELL YOU
KNOW WE ARE.
WE WE JUST BUILT A FOUR PLEX
DOWN IN THE CITY A SUSANVILLE
FIRST TIME OF GOING OFF THE
RESERVATION TO TO TO BUILD A
HOUSING WHATEVER.
SO THAT MEANS WERE NOT EXEMPT
FROM ANY OF THE BUILDING CODES
TAXES ARE ARE ANY OF THAT.
FENCE SO THAT'S YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE.
LAST I HEARD I LOOKED AT IT WAS
ANYWHERE FROM THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT THAT
WE PAID IN FOR OUR OUR BUILDING
CODES AND AND STUFF IN THAT
SENSE WITH NO PROBLEMS AT ALL --
YOU KNOW JUST THAT YOU KNOW WERE
IN THE SAME.
IS ANYBODY ELSE REALLY YOU KNOW
WE'RE JUST OUT TO TO DO WHAT WE
CAN FOR PEOPLE YOU KNOW THE BEST
THAT WE CAN TO TO OUR ABILITY --
EVEN THROUGH OUR OUR TAXES AND
AND STUFF THROUGH THAT YOU KNOW --
FOR THE EMPLOYMENT THAT WE HAVE --
THE STATE TAXES IN WHAT BUT
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW
JUST PUT AUTHORS THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE NOT A PER CAPITA TRIBE.
WE DON'T WE DON'T GIVE ALL THE
MONEY TO THE TO THE TRIBAL
MEMBERS -- WHAT WE DO PUT OR A
BIG MAJORITY THAT MONEY INTO
EDUCATION AND?
I'VE BEEN ON THE TRIBAL COUNCIL
FOR TWELVE YEARS NOW -- AND YOU
KNOW I JUST SEE THE TREMENDOUS
JOB THAT THIS IS DOING YOU KNOW
FOR OUR PEOPLE IN IN IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW A LOT OF IT IS BECAUSE
SUCH OF A LITTLE SMALL PLACE OR
AT A LOT OF US LIVE.
OFF THE RESERVATION INTO THE
BILL IN LASSEN COUNTY.
SO THAT MAKES US NOT EXEMPT FROM
ANYTHING WE JUST.
LIKE THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL WAR WE
STILL PAY THE STATE TAX AND
WHATEVER ELSE ON ON ON TOP OF
THAT.
SO BUT ANY LARGE FROM THANK YOU
GUYS FOR HAVING SIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
FROM THE PUBLIC.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
THIS JONES SAWYER.
I HAVE A ACTUALLY TWO QUESTIONS
END UP ACTUALLY ONE MAYBE IT IS
MORE OF A COMMENT YOU MIGHT BE
EVEN.
HELP US GET SOME OF OUR WORK
DONE -- AS CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS OF HOW THESE
GUNS AND GAMBLING.
BRINGING GUNS. TO TO THE RICH
RESORT -- DO YOU CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE REGISTERED --
UNDER THE CHAIRMAN MAY THINK
IT'S OKAY TO HAVE GUNS AND
GAMBLING AT THE SAME TIME.
IT WORKS SO WELL FOR WHILE BILL
HICKOK'S ALIVE JUST KIND OF
WHERE CAN THEY BRING.
THOSE WEAPONS IN I KNOW YOU SAY
THEY BRING TO ROOM.
BUT THEY DON'T BRING IT DOWN TO
THE TABLES OR ANY A NO I DON'T
KNOW I'M TRYING TO GET A FEEL
AND HOW DO YOU MAKE SURE.
NO ONE'S BRINGING IN SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE VERY HARMFUL
WITHIN.
THE CASINO SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION I'M.
THE THERE ARE NO GUNS THAT ARE
ALLOWED ON THE GAMING FLOOR.
SO OUR CASINO OF COURSE IS
SEPARATE FROM OUR HOTEL.
WE HAVE A SEPARATE ENTRANCE AND
EXIT FOR THE HOTEL -- THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW -- A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
BRINGING GUNS AND ARE ALSO OUR
CORRECTIONAL TRANSPORT AND
DRIVERS CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
TRANSPORT DRIVERS -- THERE ARE
SOME SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE
HUNTING -- ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT LASSEN COUNTY IS THAT IT
IS A BIG HUNTING AREA -- BUT YES
THEY ARE THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE LOADED WHEN THEY'RE THERE.
THEIR AMMUNITION IS SUPPOSED TO
BE SEPARATE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE KEPT IN THEIR ROOM AND OR
BEING WALKED OUT TO THEIR
VEHICLES -- OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULDN'T WANT SOMEBODY TO LEAVE
THEIR WEAPON IN THEIR VEHICLE
AND HAVE IT BROKEN INTO AND
STOLEN.
SO THIS IS MUCH SAFER WE DO HAVE
A ROOM SAFES IN THE IN THE HOTEL
ROOMS.
AND IN MY SECOND IS IT MAYBE YOU
CAN HELP US YOU KNOW I'VE HAD
SOME WILL TRY TO COME TO MY
OFFICE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
GET LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ENFORCE LAWS.
ON TRIBAL LANDS IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL
RELATIONSHIP CRITICISM BILL
POLICE DEPARTMENT -- AND THAT
WHERE -- SOMEONE COULD COME TO
CASINO CAUSE A DISTURBANCE OR A
DISH DUMPING ON TRIBAL LANDS AND
OTHER -- REALLY CRIMES AND EIGHT
FOR FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
CANNOT GET A LOCAL SHERIFF ORDER
TO COME OUT AND ACTUALLY DO
THEIR JOBS AND ARREST THESE
PEOPLE.
SO MAYBE WE CAN HAVE A SEPARATE
CONVERSATION HOW.
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET THIS CLOSE
COOPERATION BECAUSE BY LAW.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SUPPOSED TO DO
SOMETHING BUT THEY DON'T ON SOME
TRIBAL LAND SO MAYBE YOU CAN
TELL WHICH SECRETIVE.
ON IN GETTING THAT -- GOOD CLOSE
COOPERATION WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO IT IT SO JUST TO KIND OF GO
BACK A LITTLE BIT.
I'M.
AGAIN IT'S A PUBLIC WATER ANY
STATE -- ANYTHING THAT IS
CRIMINAL OBVIOUSLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE COMING ON
TO THE RANCHERIAS OR THEY'RE NOT
RESERVATIONS NECESSARILY IN.
CALIFORNIA BUT ON TO TRIBAL LAND
AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS.
WHEN I I'VE BEEN THE CHAIRWOMAN
FOR JUST ABOUT TWO YEARS NOW?
AND SO.
IN THE TWO YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
AT THE CHAIR WOMAN WE WERE
HAVING THIS LAW ENFORCEMENT
COALITION MEETING.
ONLY TWICE A YEAR.
WELL I'VE CHANGE THAT TO ONCE A
QUARTER -- I HAVE A DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIP BECAUSE I'VE ALSO
BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER.
FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AND I'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH.
THE CHIEF OF POLICE WHENEVER HE
WAS THE DA'S INVESTIGATOR AND I
SAID ON THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM AND WE YOU KNOW WE WERE
DOING AND AND INTERVIEWS WITH
CHILDREN AND THINGS SO.
I HAVE THAT RELATIONSHIP THE
GOOD THING ABOUT SUSANVILLE IS
THAT.
WERE ALL MOST OF US HAVE BEEN
BORN AND IF WE HAVEN'T LIVED
THERE ALL OF OUR LIVES WE'VE
GONE AWAY AND COME BACK.
SO JUST UTILIZING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT I HAVE
OUTSIDE OF THE RANCHERIA BUT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO COME IN -- YOU
KNOW WHAT I THINK.
AGAIN IT'S JUST TRYING TO FOSTER
A RELATIONSHIP -- A LOT OF TIMES
WE JUST LAST NIGHT WE HAD A
COMMUNITY BARBECUE THAT
COMMUNITY BARBECUE -- FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
WE HAD THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND THE CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT
THEY'RE WITH US BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING.
TO LET OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT --
YES THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
THE JOB BUT THAT ISN'T JUST TO
COME AND GET THE BAD GUYS IT'S
ALSO BECOME AND TEACH OUR
CHILDREN THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISN'T BAD THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD
THEY'RE THERE TO HELP YOU -- SO
I THINK IT'S REALLY JUST BEEN
THAT TRYING TO FOSTER
RELATIONSHIPS AND TAKING THE
TIME THE EXTRA TIME TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO LITTLE ABOUT YOU AS WELL.
THIS UP AWESOME.
CERTAINLY WILL ALLOW.
IF YOU COULD COME UP TO THE MIKE
JUST SO THAT.
OKAY ALL OF OUR VIEWERS AT HOME
START HERE.
SORRY BUT NOT JUST ON ON THAT
PART RIGHT THERE WHAT YOU ASKED
IS IS I SAID ON THE HOUSING
BOARD AS WELL AS A TRIBAL
COUNCIL.
ARM IS YOU KNOW IF IF THEY HAVE
ANY KIND OF THINGS THAT THEY
WANT TO COME UP ON THE RANCHERIA
INVESTIGATE.
US IS IS BEING IN THERE ON ON
OUR RENTAL UNITS THEY ARE FULL
ACCESS IF YOU KNOW IF IF IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY NEED THEIR WARNER
SIMON THAT SINCE.
WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE THEM THERE
AND LET A MAN IF IT IF IT COMES
TO THAT POINT IT ALSO THAT'S THE
KIND OF RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
HAVE WITH THEM AS WELL.
YOU KNOW SO IN AND WE HAVE
ANYWHERE FROM THIRTY PLUS RENTAL
HOMES UP ON THE UPPER AND LOWER
RANCHERIA.
SO THEY HAVE ACCESS TO EITHER
THE THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE OUT OF
CITY LIMITS ARE DOWN ON THE
BOTTOM WITH THE CITY YOU KNOW
POLICE OR WHATEVER SO.
ANY OF THAT STUFF ABSOLUTELY YOU
KNOW WERE THE SAME THING YOU
KNOW WE DON'T WANT THAT STUFF ON
A RANCHER IN ALL EITHER.
ANY OF THAT SO THANK.
GOOD IT SOUNDS LIKE JUST HAVING
A GOOD RELATION WITH BECAUSE
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS WHERE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BASICALLY TELLS THE TRIBE YOU
HANDLE YOURSELF AND WHEN THEY
NEED. TO ACTUALLY BE MORE
PROACTIVE AND TAKE CARE OF IT
AND SO IT SOUNDS LIKE BECAUSE
THE RELATIONSHIP.
ABSOLUTELY YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
THEM TO BE ABLE MORE PROACTIVE
AND SO I JUST I DON'T HOLD UP.
NOW BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
FURTHER CONVERSATIONAL GIVING MY
MY CARD OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
THOUGHT YOU WERE DESCRIBING
MERCED FOR MEN -- THANK YOU
ADVENTURELAND PRECIADO -- THE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE -- AS I SAID TO BE
INTRODUCTION THIS'LL.
BE COMING UP ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR FOR A VOTE OF THE ENTIRE
BODY IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
I APPRECIATE -- YOU ALL KEEPING
THE COMMITTEE UP TO SPEED ON THE
DEVELOPMENTS IN PROGRESS -- IN
THE COMPACT AND I WISH YOU THE
BEST TAKE CARE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AND WITH THAT MEMBERS -- WE ARE
JERKS